today you March the five-year
anniversary of the movie that taught us
to let it go you want to sing so bad
yeah well we're gonna flashback with the
stars who made their Disney dreams come
true I have wanted to be a part of a
Disney animated feature since I was 5
years old
I'm Jaime oh to get to play a comic
relief in a Disney film doesn't get much
better than that hi I'm Olaf and I like
warm hugs I have to roll Emma and then
go in a steamy shower and warm up my
voice so I can sing a song like let it
go
two oscars and 1.2 billion dollars at
the box office
five years later frozen still ranks as
the highest-grossing animated film of
all time you know the movie success
surprised me I mean it was kind of crazy
yeah I mean I think we all thought it
was good but you never know when the
right recipe is gonna hit at the right
time and people were just ready for it
now after two short films at a Broadway
show
Disney is finally getting ready to give
us the frozen sequel we have all been
waiting for
here's everything we know about the film
out next November first up the og cast
is back do you feel the pressure I don't
feel the pressure it's it's nice to kind
of go in the studio no makeup and play
you know and expect some new faces we
hear Evan Rachel Wood and sterling K
Brown are joining
there's a new character they want to
introduce it would be an opportunity to
do something that my kid it's definitely
can watch the plot is on lockdown but
one of the director says Queen Elsa will
have a little more fun this time around
and as for the music I've heard quite a
few of the time yes they are still in my
head
ugh let it go was like I don't I don't
know that I can ever say something's
gonna outdo let it go because that might
truly be the song of the century but
there will be some contenders
the cold never bothered me anyway
[Music]